so you recently posted this um old
picture and this was you and Britney
y'all were young um so younger I should
say but Britney actually just released a
memoir as well and she said something
really cool so I'm going to tell
everybody so it says one of the people
who was kindest to me when I really
needed kindness was Paris Hilton like
that's you know I don't feel like good
news gets spread often it's always like
this person did this to me this person
it's always bad I thought it was really
cool to like read something kind about
someone and like lift that up did you
feel good about that yeah I was crying
when I read that I thought that was just
that really touched me she's just so
strong I love her so much and I'm just
so proud of her for speaking her truth
and writing this whole book and yeah
that quote just meant a lot to me when I
read it yeah and you both were very
young in this industry and like growing
up that can't be easy so well you know
how it is yeah I I feel like there has
to be purpose in things that happen to
us the good and the bad and I love that
you're a really big advocate for like
trouble teen industry like anything
going on in that area because you had
struggled that's really cool so that's
important to you to keep up yes and I'm
just so proud of all the impact that
I've made with telling my story I've now
changed laws in 10 states and going back
and forth to Washington DC and we're
pushing for federal legislation and
we've made it bipartisan so we have both
sides that are supporting this so
congratulations that never happens yeah
really proud that's really cool like cuz
I think that people look at you like
from afar and maybe don't know like your
life now they will with the Memoir but
like I don't think they know that and so
it's kind of cool for people that are
struggling to go okay I can do this like
she did this I think that's really
important you yeah and changing laws
you're doing everything
[Music]
[Applause]
okay thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home